[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome very good to be with
you and have your company
how dangerous can fiction really be my
guest today a turkish writer and
political scientist has been
investigated by the authorities of her
home country for simply writing novels
accused of being anti-turkish and
inciting crimes through her writing she
has fought back and continued to defy
her critics
alif shafak through her fiction
including her latest novel the island of
missing trees covers politics identity
and the expectations of women
she has also won a claim for defining
the 40 rules of love
now a british citizen she continues to
campaign for women's rights both in what
she calls her motherland turkey and
around the world elif shafak welcome
thank you so much it's lovely to be with
you and i thought we could start with
what you call your motherland turkey and
do you think that people outside of
turkey realize how challenging the
circumstances are inside it
i don't think many people realize that
turkey as you know has become a
difficult place for anyone who deals
with words
so poets writers journalists of course
but also cartoonists for instance humor
itself can also be regarded as dangerous
when democracy is lost
so that makes it very difficult you know
when you don't have freedom of speech it
makes the life of a writer difficult
many people of course understand that it
might be
not that easy to question political
issues but sometimes people don't
realize that it's equally challenging to
write about sexuality gender
discrimination
child abuse so all those issues can also
be very difficult subjects to tackle
i want to come to the investigation of
you in in short order but on that point
of our view of turkey outside turkey
do you think it's outdated what we think
of as turkey because what's happened has
been quite gradual
there's there's no doubt in my mind this
is such a beautiful country it's a very
complex country
and i would i would never associate the
government and the people you know the
civil society in turkey is of course far
more multi-layered nuanced
but we do have a very
conservative government that has become
more and more authoritarian over the
years under erdogan under arduino so
what we've seen in turkey is the country
under erdogan has been going backwards
and declining into ultra-nationalism
islamism populist authoritarianism when
and where that happens we will also see
an increase in sexism misogyny
homophobia in my opinion these things
always go hand in hand there must be
many though who are in support or do you
see it as a mask there are some in
support of course
but for all kinds of reasons
and as you pointed out this government
has been in power for a very long time
they came to power with liberal promises
of reform at the time they were turkey's
eu membership do you consider turkey i
say you used to call it your motherland
but do you consider it your home you
know what is your identity as far as
your concern because you're someone
who's paid a lot of attention to that i
care about this question so much
identity for me it's not a static solid
single thread you know it's not a
monolithic block i want to think of
identity as more fluid
more multiple and i think as human
beings we all contain multitudes like
walt whitman used to say the problem is
we're living in a world that doesn't
allow us to be multiple let alone
celebrate our own multiplicity so for me
rather than identity
singular what i care about more is
multiple belongings if i have a singular
identity if you have a singular identity
it's much harder for us to understand
what we have in common but the moment we
understand and embrace these concentric
circles of belongings then we realize
actually so much of it overlaps
you said of your own country your
motherland in 2014 i get a lot of
criticism from the cultural elite and a
lot of love from readers the more you
are read in the western world the more
you are hated in your motherland do you
think that's still the case has it got
worse or got better in the intervening
years i wish i could say that you know
we made a lot of progress in turkey in
terms of freedom of speech but i'm
afraid it's quite the opposite in 2006 i
was put on trial for writing a novel
called the bastard of istanbul which
tells the story of a turkish family and
an armenian-american family and it deals
with memory and amnesia as you know in
turkey we have a very long history rich
history but that doesn't translate into
strong memory in fact i think it's quite
the opposite we're a society of
collective amnesia and our entire
relationship with the past is full of
ruptures and that void is filled in by
ultra nationalist and islamist
interpretations of the past so when this
book came out the novel came out i was
put on trial for insulting turkishness
under article 301 this is an article in
the turkish constitution which has been
used against journalists against
scholars but it was the first time it
was used against the work of fiction and
it was quite surreal as well because the
words of fictional characters were
plucked they were taken out of the text
and used as evidence in the courtroom as
a result of which my turkish lawyer had
to defend my armenian fictional
characters in the courtroom so your
characters were on trial my characters
were on trial alongside because myself
you fought this yeah and what happened
so that madness went on for about a year
and there were groups on the streets
ultra nationalists spitting out my
pictures burning eu flags because for
them anyone who questions official
history is a pawn of western powers and
then i was acquitted at the end of that
what toll did that have on you because
that sounds like it was something to
really live through
it was quite unsettling i mean i i you
know i have to be honest to myself it
did shake me quite a bit also because i
was pregnant at the time so the day i
was acquitted the next day i gave uh
birth so just one day apart the
the birth and really the acquittal so
you know that whole year was quite um
unsettling for me and it was not that
easy but of course many people go
through so much worse so i don't want to
put too much emphasis on that and at the
same time i did receive amazingly
heartwarming letters at the time from
readers
um and and the reason why i mentioned
you know where we are right now is a
couple of years ago in 2019 again
this time i was investigated for crime
of obscenity for writing about sexual
harassment for gender violence i write
about these issues because this is the
reality of the land where i come from
and what happened with those
investigations um it did not turn into a
trial but the very fact that police
officers come to a publishing house the
very fact that they confiscate novels
works of fiction and they take to a
prosecutor is is quite unsettling
your works are hugely successful and
widely read around the world that when
you started writing in english i know
that was a a big deal for you but again
you've been labelled a traitor for doing
so making your name easier for
westerners to pronounce and all of that
but how much do you think you've been
targeted because you're also a woman
it's difficult to be a novelist in
turkey because novelists deal with
issues
about identity belonging memory amnesia
you know the canvas of a novel is so
nuanced it's not easy to be a novelist
but honestly i think it's much harder or
it's you know
perhaps more difficult to be a woman
novelist because additionally you have
to deal with sexism and misogyny as well
what is going on in turkey with regards
to women
is extraordinarily bad on on many many
levels i mean you know nearly every day
a woman is killed
uh the levels of domestic violence
and how actually it's not investigated
is is something that it cannot almost be
stressed enough the country leaving the
istanbul convention earlier this year no
reason was given that was all about a
document signed in istanbul
all about the prevention of gender-based
violence
what is your understanding just first of
all of why erdogan walked away from that
or his government did
we have seen an escalation in cases of
femicides in turkey and there are so
many other stories that go
uninvestigated for instance there are
very suspicious suicides are they really
suicides
so this is this is an urgent issue for
women and children and minorities in
turkey but instead of doing something
about it instead of changing the laws
and instead of implementing istanbul
convention because signing it is not
enough you need to ratify you need to
implement it put it into practice so
instead of doing all that what the
government did was the exact opposite
they also launched this very horrible
similar campaign misinformation
saying that the islamic convention is
actually against our traditional values
and then one night at night time the
government decided to withdraw
its you know from istanbul convention
without really consulting women without
really consulting the civil society and
ever since women have been bravely on
the streets protesting there are many
women in turkey who are incredibly
strong and vocal and have so much
respect from for them
and when you look at academia media
medicine you will find them everywhere
but except in one field where there are
very few women especially as you go up
the echelons of decision-making and
that's politics and that makes a huge
difference
so the ones who are making the decisions
are usually very patriarchal
conservative
men you use the word femicide and
actually not everybody uses it but you
know nearly every day of the year a
woman is killed and that's only the
people who are recorded the women who
were recorded in turkey do you think
it's important as someone who thinks all
the time about what words to use that
that word is used and that it passes
into common parlance yes i think it's so
important we need to use the word
femicide we need we need to use the word
misogyny but also we need to understand
that hate speech directed against women
is a crime
and it leads to other crimes so every
case shows this and i don't think i have
to mention social media alongside the
role of media in which unfortunately
it's always women who are put under the
magnifying glass what was she wearing
what was she doing at that hour of the
night you know why was she out
immediately or why didn't she defend
herself immediately we start questioning
women this narrative has to change
and i think we also need to understand
unfortunately with a pandemic we have
seen an increase in domestic violence
all across the world there was a recent
report that showed over in over 40
countries the amount of abuse that women
journalists women politicians any women
in the public space have been receiving
has escalated so tech companies also
need to wake up to the fact that this is
hate speech we're talking about and they
need to take it seriously
with regards of course i mean men
receive an awful amount of abuse as well
but it is augmented differently uh
towards women and and for what reason it
is given and and i suppose
how you can tackle that i mean some
would say
technology is just reflecting the ills
that's already there in society
and it's actually for society to change
as opposed to the platforms but there
has been a move away from that position
i i think we need to talk about um
take companies
in in a different way in the sense that
for me particularly digital platforms
social media is a bit like the moon it
definitely has a bright side of course
it does connect us it does give people
more voice especially in countries where
there are no media freedoms
or in countries where there's no equal
space in the urban public space for
instance for women many young women can
carve out a space for themselves in
digital platforms i do not belittle any
of that however because we have over
romanticized the bright side of
technology and because we had this take
optimism of early 2000s which was so
arrogant as well because the expectation
was you know if you bring facebook and
social media every country is going to
become a democracy that's not true
because of all of that we urgently need
to focus on the darker side of social
media platforms and we need to
understand how they spread this
information misinformation and hate
speech
to come to you know i mean i would the
the technology companies would say they
are working on that that is something
they're now looking at or have been
looking at i mean i was reading about
your your early life you said that that
book saved you
why was that
my parents were in france i was born in
france but afterwards they got separated
and my father stayed in france and in
the meantime my mother brought me to
ankara to turkey to a very conservative
neighborhood very patriarchal
neighborhood this was my grandmother's
house
but grandma herself was interesting she
was a bit like a matriarch and people
would come to her and her house was full
of superstitions
you know lots of stories of the of the
middle east and oral culture although
most of my upbringing and my education
was in turkey i think i also felt the
need to start writing in english even
though as you can hear in my accent in
my broken accent as well
i'm an immigrant in this language
english for me is an acquired language
it's a much more cerebral connection my
connection with the turkish language is
more emotional but writing in english
gave me an additional sense of freedom
and i needed that
to this day i realize if i if my writing
has more sorrow in it if it has more
longing or melancholy i find these
things much easier to express in turkish
really but when it comes to humor which
i love and irony and satire i find that
much easier in english what language do
you dream in that's always the test do
you mean do you dream in both i dream in
both i dream a lot in english when i'm
writing in english of course i dream
primarily mostly in english but i can
dream yeah
i love asking people who
speak a few languages where they are
with that because it's a bit of a moment
when you you switch over that's so true
and the mind is fascinating isn't it
because it doesn't recognize these
national borders that we take for
granted you so you can't ask for your
passport in your sleep not at all so you
can't start the same dream in turkish
and ended in in english
and it also fascinates me when i observe
many immigrants or or many families from
complex backgrounds sometimes they like
to express their anger or frustration in
one language or another so that switch
back and forth is so clever
in the latest book the island of missing
trees why or what was the moment you
thought i'd quite like to write from the
perspective of a fig tree that was such
a risk to be honest i was aware that it
was risk for an author because if it
doesn't work the whole thing collapses
the whole edifice collapses but it felt
right like the right thing to do
and if i may take a step back i've been
wanting to write about cyprus for a very
long time which is what the book which
is where the where the book um partly
takes place
and it's a beautiful island with
beautiful people north and south but at
the same time it's a very difficult
story to tell and as you know as we're
speaking there's a there's a border
there's a frontier partition line that
literally separates christians from
muslims greek sepias from turkish
cypriots so depending on whom you talk
to north or south there are clashing
memories and there are wounds and the
wounds are unhealed i couldn't find the
gate into the story i've been thinking
reading researching
only when i found the voice of the fig
tree it allowed me to separate myself
from these nationalistic boxes and take
another look and then i felt more free
to tell the story but about what people
don't say that's also a theme in the
book and it's about what you don't say
to your children how you protect them
potentially from painful pasts what you
as a family have perhaps fled from or
escaped from you have two children and i
i wonder how much you've navigated that
with your own children what you say
about why you really left when you left
turkey you know having your mother being
heavily pregnant with you uh while being
investigated in the way that you've
described to me today
is extraordinary yes these are not easy
conversations to have i'm aware of that
at the same time as a as a novelist i
also love to be an intellectual nomad to
the best of my abilities so i need to
look at the story from the perspective
of multiple generations and the reason
why i say this is because i think in
many immigrant families or any family
that comes from a complex background
there are these
striking differences as you move from
one generation to the next the first
generation are usually the ones who have
experienced the biggest hardships
traumas
obstacles and they carry those memories
within but they don't know how to talk
about them so they don't the second
generation especially after a
displacement they don't they're not
interested in the past and
understandably they have to be
forward-looking they need to find their
feet build a new life you know
assimilate tubular
let's move forward and therefore it's
the third or the fourth generations in
these families the youngest in these
families who are asking the strongest
questions about identity memory their
ancestors journeys and i find that very
striking that sometimes you can meet
young people carrying old memories it's
so true are you have you made a decision
then based on that to try and skip being
the generation because you have moved
and changed that doesn't answer the
questions or comes forward are you
trying to disrupt that i want to disrupt
that i want to you know
understand those silences because i
think silences keep us apart and they
also deepen and widen the existing hurts
and inequalities but stories bring us
together if we understand each other's
stories
then we can we can feel
someone else's psychology
i i'm someone who thinks about a lot
emotion about emotions and i think we're
living in an age of angst and it's not
easy to be young in this age it feels to
me like many young people they have a
almost a scream building up inside and
they want to unleash it at us because we
are they think we're destroying rightly
so that we're destroying this world for
them it's going to impact their future
so it's a moment of anxiety fear
disappointment bewilderment anger as
well but i think rather than questioning
these emotions the real question is what
do we do with these emotions you know
what do we do with our anger what do we
do with our anxiety can we turn it into
something more positive there's only one
emotion that really scares me and that's
the lack of all emotions
that's numbness the moment we stop
listening to each other the moment we
become indifferent differently you know
that's i think a much darker world that
scream of anger has made me recall that
i read you're a heavy metal fan
is that how you release a leaf
i love heavy metal i always love of
course you do that's exactly what i
thought when you walked in today do you
really i do i do very much so since my
early youth you know people don't expect
a middle-aged turkish woman to love
heavy metal but i do is that what you're
listening to when you roast as the fig
tree yes i do listen to heavy metal
particularly the sub-genres like
industrial metal gothic more metal core
viking scandinavian
i've literally got no idea what you're
talking about
you also penned the 40 rules of love
what's the most important one i think
they're all
related
i
i think love is so powerful and it
transforms us and we need to allow
ourselves to be transformed and i think
one of the rules mentioned in this in
the book was um is about freedom you
know where there's no freedom there's
there's no love so love is not about
possessiveness
you know my fiance my partner my
girlfriend the emphasis is always on my
but it's not about ownership love
freedom and love makes me think of your
your ted talk back in 2017 where just
towards the end uh you said you've never
been brave enough to admit that you i
think you said it in the past tense that
you were bisexual no i said i am you say
i am but i never had the courage to say
to say it
yeah and
i watched that talk and it is right
towards the end and it's great to hear
it in its full context but of course
what was taken from that is you came out
yeah um and you had been scared of of
the shame the ridicule how has it been
since
um it's well unfortunately again from my
motherland the the level of shaming
ridicule hate speech
verbal abuse has been
has been awful but i was ready to
weather that storm and i wish i had the
courage to come out earlier even though
it's very visible in my writing even
though i've always been very vocal about
my support for lgbtq plus rights i never
had the courage to say also this is my
story
but about um with regards to feedback or
or you know the comments coming from
listeners or readers from other parts of
the world it has been incredibly
heartwarming and also from my motherland
i i need to add this um from families
particularly of
children who are lgbtq themselves or or
both young and older generations that
have been very heartwarming and very
moving letters
quietly whispering you know words of
support but i had to go through that a
lot of abuse afterwards it's interesting
i was looking at some of the the
feedback that was certainly public and
you know there's the type that you
described in terms of the ante but there
was also a sense of as i believe you're
married to a man um why did you need to
say this we're beyond being you know
being able to be in a position where you
have to come out anymore but of course
different parts of the world and
different parts of society are at such
different stages of that aren't they and
i wonder do you still do you still think
today it's important to be able to say
those things or do you think we're post
that in some way i think it's always
important to to share our stories
um and
one of the things that happens to us is
when you live
you know when you deal with
authoritarianism when you deal with any
ideology or structure that divides human
beings into boxes and denies their
freedoms what happens is people feel
very lonely people feel like am i the
only one who's feeling this way but when
you hear someone else's story
then you realize you're not alone and
that is very important there are amazing
authors from lgbtq plus communities
authors poets speakers who have given me
amazing energy and and motivation and
inspiration
so i felt like i i had a responsibility
to share this
primarily to myself but also to anyone
who might be feeling alone
elizabeth thank you so much for talking
to me thank you so much i really
appreciate it it's fascinating me too
thank you
thank you so much for being with us and
until we meet again mask up stay safe
and goodbye
[Music]
you